Film Courage: What’s your process for approaching
dialogue?
Erik Bork, Screenwriter/Author: It’s kind
of instinctual I think.
Once I know what is happening in the scene
and I know where it’s going, where the characters
enter the scene.
It’s all about:
*Whose scene is it?
*What are they trying to achieve in that scene?
*What is in the way?
*What are they doing in trying to get through
whatever is in the way?
That’s pretty much the template for every
scene.
Then part of that is going to be dialogue,
part of that is going to be what they say.
And what they say should be the things that
they would believably say given who they are
and what their unique voice and way of speaking
is in that situation given what is going on
and what they want.
You want to avoid the mistake that people
often make with expositional dialogue where
people just speak information that the audience
needs to know but they really wouldn’t say
in that moment.
You want them to be saying the things that
they would really say.
When I’m doing it it is kind of instinctual
and I’m just sort of quickly writing what
I have people say and then maybe go back and
revise it but what is probably in the back
of my mind is it needs to be what they would
naturally say given who they are and what
they want.
And people don’t always express everything
they want, right?
The best dialogue has subtext.
Which means the audience can pick up that
they’re thinking and feeling something they
are not saying but what they are saying is
what they think is the right thing to say
to try and get whatever it is that they want.
Or the only thing they are able to say for
whatever reason given who they are and what’s
going on.
But what is helpful is there’s a sense of
subtext of we know what the inner life is
underneath that they are not saying.
But what they are saying hopefully feels real
for that character and hopefully is entertaining
and keeping with whatever the genre is.
I mean if it’s a comedy obviously your dialogue
is going to often be trying to be funny as
well.
So yes, it’s not so much of figuring it
out as it’s just an instinctually moving
through it with those kind of things in the
back of my mind and of course tons of revising,
going back and rewriting and revising, compressing,
cutting, editing the dialogue over time.
Film Courage: Are there certain scenes that
stand out that are great for subtext?
What’s a great study in that?
Erik: Well Robert McKee in this book STORY
analyzed the scene in CASABLANCA with Humphrey
Bogart and Ingrid Bergman where he gives you
on the page all of the dialogue in the scene.
He explains to you what subtext is so that’s
a great thing that stayed with me the most
from that book.
It was a really helpful thing.
There is that scene in ANNIE HALL, the famous
scene where Alvy is at Annie’s apartment
and he is looking around at the photos on
the wall and he is saying stuff and then the
subtitles they tell you the subtext which
is like “You are a really attractive girl.”
But what he’s saying is “That’s a really
interesting use of negative space.”
And her subtext is “I hope he is not a jerk
like the others.”
But what she is saying is “Oh really?
You think so?”
So it’s a comedic thing but it’s kind
of showing you what subtext is.
Film Courage: I think Humphrey Bogart was
sort of the master of subtext because so much
of what he says is sarcasm…but without saying
much there is a look, there is a jab, and
there a lot of things he’s not overtly saying.
Erik: Good question.
I don’t know.
I mean I don’t know how much credit to give
actors for it because it’s really in the
writing to some extent.
You need to see the characters to have that
inner life that is going to be clear to the
audience but also have dialogue on the page
that is not exactly what you are thinking
and feeling where you can feel the gap.
At the same time it’s a big part of acting
to know what am I really feeling and thinking
because I’m not saying it and what am I
saying and how I portray what I am really
thinking and feeling to the audience even
though I am sort of hiding it away in my dialogue
or I am not quite coming out with it in my
dialogue for whatever reason.
Obviously there are great actors who do that
particularly well.
Film Courage: Do you think certain decades
of cinema have more or less subtext?
Erik: I don’t know about that.
I would say that television writing traditionally
has tended to have less subtext especially
kind of what we originally think of as Prime
Time Network Dramas and comedies usually have
a lot of dialogue and the dialogue tends to
be a little more on the surface with just
saying whatever it is that people are thinking
and feeling.
Although nowadays when we have all of these
TV shows that are more movie like and then
they have a different feel to them you might
see a lot of subtext and dialogue there as
you might do in movies.
It’s a more like slightly sophisticated
kind of thing which isn’t necessarily present
in certain genres like if it’s Bruce Willis
in DIE HARD there is probably not a lot of
subtext right?
Or if it’s SOUTH PARK, it’s not filled
with subtext right?
But serious dramas tend to have more subtext
or…I hate to use a pejorative where “it’s
good if you have it and bad if you don’t.”
But to some extent that’s true that it tends
to be more interesting and involving if we
are seeing people who aren’t saying everything
they are really thinking.
I don’t know if you’ve seen FLEABAG on
Amazon?
It’s a series that I recently watched both
seasons of.
It has this great device where the main character
turns to the camera and kind of tells us sometimes
her subtext and it’s this running dialogue
with the camera which they did a little bit
of in HOUSE OF CARDS and other shows have
done it too in their own unique way so that
the audience is in on it.
She doesn’t give us every bit of subtext
but she gives us some point in looks and moments
of what she is really thinking but she is
saying something different.
Film Courage: I mean this in all seriousness,
you think of Bruce Willis in the TV show MOONLIGHTING
and it has tons of subtext between he the
Sybil Shepherd.
Erik: Yes, it depends on the genre.
It’s not about if the actor does or doesn’t
do it, it’s about the project.
Film Courage: So you don’t think that certain
actors get more roles or are cast in terms
of this?
You think of Samuel L. Jackson’s characters
and he is so great in everything he does and
he’s just going to say what he feels.
But you know at some point in the film his
character is going to have a mini-meltdown
and everyone is going to be at his mercy and
they are going to do what he wants.
Certain actors seem to get roles in more of
one style or another.
Erik: I mean they may get cast in roles that
are not subtext-ty roles more I suppose but
I don’t know if certain actors do subtext
and some don’t or some are and some aren’t.
I think it is more of a writing thing.
It’s more what kind of scene is it?
Because we are really talking about scene
level dialogue on the scene level so what
kind of scene is it?
Who are the people in the scene?
What are the agendas?
What are they trying to communicate or achieve
and what are they really thinking and feeling
and are those things going to be in the dialogue
or not kind of just depends on the kind of
genre and kind of scene.
Film Courage: So Aaron Sorkin maybe less subtext?
Gillian Flynn maybe more with GONE GIRL?
Erik: That’s a good point.
Aaron Sorkin I think is less subtext because
he tends to write these very smart people
articulately laying out arguments for things.
I think of THE WEST WING classically that
way.
So yes, it’s not subtext-ty for the most
part.
It’s very come out and say your opinion
and argue it with somebody.
It’s kind of an intellectual cerebral type
of writing.
I think it’s engaging on that level.
It’s entertaining on that level.
I’m not saying that he doesn’t ever have
scenes that have subtext.
I’m sure he does.
If you look at THE SOCIAL NETWORK I could
probably imagine scenes that have a lot of
subtext where Justin Timberlake is on the
phone with Eduardo and he is saying one thing
but we know what he really means.
There is stuff that Aaron never does or can’t
do it’s just the style he is most known
for like from THE WEST WING I think you’re
right, it is less subtext-ty.